today's changing world needs principled
leaders who are intentional about
developing their own personal leadership
competencies and values this is why
we're so excited about this new course
which will be the foundation for the
lead personal leadership certificate
Brian can you tell us a little bit more
about the course of course so in this
course we're gonna blend research
practical exercises and a 360 tools so
the participants in the course will be
able to better craft their own personal
leadership journey
so who's the course for Sarah so this
course is terrific for the new leader as
well as for the seasoned executive new
leaders will learn about their own
strengths and weaknesses and use this
information to both craft their own
personal leadership journey and chart
their course through the certificate but
because personal leadership is always an
evolving journey it's important for the
more seasoned leader to examine their
leadership habits critically and make
course corrections as needed in other
words we've designed this course to be
useful for both new and seasoned leaders
Brian tell us a little more about how
the course is set up
mm-hmm this course provides leadership
lessons from a number of experts who
will share their own unique knowledge of
a given topic the topics we have curated
for the course focus on building the
core competencies of personal leadership
which are self-awareness perspective
taking awareness of the context in which
interaction takes place communication
and decision making participants will
leave this course with a much deeper
knowledge about themselves as leaders
and this will allow them to begin to
chart their own personal leadership
journey